hello how are y'all doing good yeah
though that one person thank you very
much
Suzy as I'm on a Thursday morning I'm
Martin BB I'm a principal developer
advocate AWS and we'll be talking about
building real-time service apps in
Blaser using AWS it's quite the mouthful
of a title um I'm at the Beeb's on
twitter feel free to follow me on there
and we're gonna be discussing oh it's
not even working we're gonna be
discussing what I mean by real-time
applications and clarify that before we
get going and then we gonna be looking
at how we build real-time applications
using signal are and how you might be
doing that today and I'll take you an
example of an existing signal
application and show you how that would
work in in AWS then I would sort of look
at new way of architecting a this is the
same sort of application but using
service technologies and then finally
we're gonna look about integrating that
or how we'd go about integrating that
into a blazer application this is
possibly personally the most important
slide is anyone got camera phone here
and anyone that cameraphone which you've
got access to Twitter if someone could
take a picture of me in front of this
slide it would be really awesome and the
reason is it would be it'll be
it's important for me it's called my
inception slide and it's me standing in
front of slide
I'm sorry slide in front of a slide in
front of a slide in front of a slide
it's 42 levels deep uh none forked like
I've actually got 82 pictures of me
standing up full of slides but they're
not all unique like in in a line but
this one is is inner line so if someone
can tweet that at me at the beads
inception then I will somehow get to
level 42 or 43 and I'm speaking tonight
as well in Leeds so hopefully I'll get
to 43 or 44 and the the goal of this
exercise is to get to level 100 which I
think will be a lifetime achievement
exactly and I'm a software developer
I've been a software developer since I
was 16 years old I have been developing
now for nearly 21 years I've not updated
my slide and I'll do the math on that
that makes me 21 years old and and I
work at Amazon Web Services and I
previously worked
call for a year and prior to that worked
at Microsoft for eight years as a
software engineer and also as an
evangelist and so what are we talking
about today what's real-time or what do
I mean by real-time and there's lots of
differences and lots of people give
different terminology around real-time
so I thought I'd just clarify what I
mean by it
I mean interactive apps and websites
which react to events that happen in the
real world I'm not talking about
building really really hot low-latency
it's sort of trading applications and
that sort of thing and I'm talking more
about kind of building regular kind of
applications which are which don't
require the kind of level of like low
latency which M some of those sorts of
hard real-time applications might
require so some people will prefer to
this is soft real-time but I'll just
call it real-time real times kind of all
around us it's in applications which we
all use mobile applications
browser-based applications IOT devices
any kind of device which you'll use it's
probably got some level of real-time
activity and sort of application
programming model so if you're thinking
about something like whatsapp and you're
sending messages obviously the messages
which are being sent that's happening in
real time and somehow they are
processing those things and sending you
events when you get new messages but
also like more subtle things in that
application like when someone's read or
your your message you get this double
ticks or when this when it's been
delivered you get a single tick those
events are things have happened in the
real world which are getting fed back to
you in the user interface and that's a
real-time notification which is
happening in on mobile phones there is
obviously the notification and push
systems but generally speaking when
we're building real-time applications
we're still very much relying on on
WebSockets and and and web protocols so
things like banking alerts or new story
updates if you ever want a website a
news website and a breaking alert comes
up and it pops up and says there's a
breaking news story they had to push
that event to you and that ability to be
able to push stuff from the server to
client is what real-time really is
because the whole basis of the web was
built with by timber
in his pink bunker in CERN on the basis
of you know going to a website
requesting something from a server and
the server responding to your request it
was never based upon the idea that the
server would have some new information
and send it to the user
so for over the over the years we've
developed like techniques from long
calling through to server sent events
through to WebSockets to enable us to do
real-time applications and you you know
every kind of application shared
whiteboards VR and AR experiences and
things like hololens or when you're
trying to update the position of other
people in the experience that you're in
that's all real-time information
document collaboration if you've ever
used Google Docs and you're working
together with other people that's all
happening over some form of real-time
collaboration real-time application
platform and then if you're you know now
inside of Visual Studio and you're doing
like live sharing you're pairing with
someone which in a remote region or
somewhere which is not in your you know
in your app to I say one thing about
live show which I'm not that happy with
is the fact that now I have to do like I
have to have my peers review my code in
real time that used to be one of the
advantages of working remote is that no
one knew how bad I was so now now is
we've got with real-time collaboration
we can figure out just how bad I am in
real time so it's it's that's cool and
so but all of those things are using
under the covers some form of real-time
technology and those ones in particular
they're using signal are that that
particular one with live share and if
you ever use Microsoft Office online
that's using signal are under the hub
under the covers and there's other
flying flight libraries and frameworks
like socket IO and in node and various
other different platforms but it's all
about giving the user sort of feedback
about events that happening in the world
and so I might be on the this is the
hotel I stayed in last night just down
the road here in Westminster and I was
on this website and the website just
pops up this saying just booked 52
properties like Doubletree and help
London would just booked in the last 15
minutes on your site you've got a book
you've got to put this website it's got
a book it now because it's gonna go
you're going to lose your hotel this is
slightly illegal this this sort of
capability now but the and but this is
like a real-time event that's
just booked that hotel why she were
looking at our hotel and they're giving
you that information to try and
encourage you to go and buy that hotel
and it's a at all I mean what they could
have also done is just have a JavaScript
timer on 30 seconds and just pop that up
you know it might not be a real-time
thing it depends how good an engineering
job they've done but like the idea is
that it's a real-time event which is
being pushed to the to the use of based
upon something which is happening in the
real world
and we use a collaboration tool called
quip at AWS I think it's by Salesforce
that build it and if you produce a
document and you share it you can see
all the people which are currently
looking at that document so you can see
there's two people viewing that
marketing budget review and usually this
is an I always find this is a fun game
is that if you send an email out and say
hey could someone review my document and
you'll find that no one views it what
you can do is say can someone review
their document I've included the
salaries of all the people in the
department everyone starts viewing it
and you start seeing people show up
there and but that viewing is that's
real-time right when you go when those
other users go to that browser that's
fires an event that event gets sent to a
centralized system that centralized
system then distributes it to the other
connected clients and shows them who's
viewing and looking at that document in
the same application there's a chat sort
of feature and you know Ron sports is
typing and he's trying to tightly sort
of a message this is possibly one of the
most annoying UI elements in the world
by the way the dot dot they're typing
I've lost many an hour on whatsapp like
all the typing I'm not gonna say anymore
all the typing they're typing yeah so
anyway but but that's happening you know
as he touches the keyboard in his
application that's sending an event to
some centralized service it's ultimately
updating my UI to say that they're there
typing so the the main way that this is
happening the main technology that
people are using is WebSockets that's
the the although that's not completely
true in that there are many examples of
real-time applications which are using
other techniques like long polling and
and various other things but but for the
majority of times its web sockets and
web sockets requires both the
application and the server to support
the
web web socket capability this was like
a standard which was defined by what a
working group and then implemented by
all of the browsers it's also been
implemented in practically every
application platform that comes the comp
the ability to create a web socket you
could do that from a c-sharp console for
example you can console application you
could do it from an iOS application you
could do for an Android application you
can do it in a web browser creating a
web socket to communicate information
and the way it works is there's a
negotiation which happens between the
app and the server because when it was
initially launched not every app and not
every server and every client made let's
put in a bad word and not every server
supported WebSockets so they had this
handshake negotiation over port 80 is
HTTP request which goes from client to
server which says I support WebSockets
do you support WebSockets and then the
web server like says of course it's 2020
of course I support WebSockets and then
they create a channel a duplex
communication channel way that not only
the client can send information but the
server can send information back to the
client at will as long as the connection
is maintained and so what's good about a
WebSocket is also with a HTTP request
every time you make a HTTP request you
get everything all the payload like
includes things like cookies can things
about everything it's all included on
every single request so it's quite a
heavy thing to make HTTP requests it
includes information about what browser
you are using all that stuff gets
transferred with every HTTP request with
WebSockets on the negotiation that
information is is shared but once a
WebSocket is established the information
which is passed for back and forth is
just the messages so it means it's much
luck once you've established a WebSocket
connection you get much lower latency
sort of connections between to to a
client and the server so I got involved
very much in real time stuff when signal
are originally came out for dotnet
full-fat the full-fat framework and
David Fowler I started following David
for hollering like obsessing over all
every project that he ever worked on
because he's a genius
but the signal I was one which was
particularly interesting because it was
and building a sort of a really simple
framework to enable us to do real-time
stuff and sigmaz still to this day
remains one of the fav my most favorite
frameworks I've ever used it's fantastic
sore developer productivity a way of
building things and it's fantastic and
when I joined AWS I had a signal our
project I thought well how would I
actually run a signal art project on AWS
what would I need to do what sorts of
things would I need to install so figure
out if you've not used it before seen it
before it's just an open source of
framework for basically doing
WebSockets it does a little bit more
than just WebSockets but it does
WebSockets communication for in real
time it makes it very very simple to
write real time applications and and
it's effectively an MVC application so
you end up with an MVC application and
you can deploy it to your iOS web server
and as long as the IAS web server has
its WebSockets port open and it's a new
enough version of iis then you will be
pretty easy to just go and create a
client a web application which just
connects up to the signal our hub and it
will communicate using some JavaScript
libraries which have been developed part
of the fritz signal framework and if
you've got one single machine on the
backend everything will be absolutely
fine because you're the client will
connect to one single server and there's
no real complication in that but it
starts becoming more complicated when
you add more than one server because I
mentioned that a WebSocket communication
is between a single client and a single
server that's like a pipe imagining
between the two of them and so if you've
got a load balance system and a user
comes back to the load balancer and is
assigned a different machine that pipe
is no longer like the client thinks the
pipe still exists because it's assuming
it's speaking to the same machine but
this the server's like I've never seen
you before and so the it disrupts the
sort of the transmission so one thing
that you'll have to do with whatever
system you're using if you're using a
load balancer is you have
make sure that your load balance of
support sticky sessions the idea being
that when you connect to the load
balancer the load balancer will send you
to a machine and then subsequently on
subsequent requests will always send you
back to that same machine that's what we
call sticky sessions at a load balancer
Amazon have a very very good has this I
guess platform as a service offering
called elastic beanstalk and it's
basically pretty much any web
application framework you want to use
like whether it's Ruby or whether it's
PHP or where it's dotnet you build your
application you send your code over to
elastic Beanstalk and then they'll
deploy it on a number of servers and you
can say I want one server I want five
servers and the idea is they manage the
servers and they manage the code it was
that doesn't sound revolutionary like
but that at the time when it was
released in 2010 and istick Beanstalk
was like the very one of the very first
sort of offerings like that and
obviously we've got different services
now around containers and there's
different ways of doing this stuff but
but elastic Beanstalk still still exists
and lots of customers use it and it's a
great way of deploying you know your
first application in visual studio if
you have the AWS toolkit installed in
visual studio you can just right-click a
project say publish to elastic Beanstalk
it will wrap up your application publish
it to elastic Beanstalk and do
everything you need to right from within
visual Studios relatively
straightforward to do that sort of stuff
and so I'd adept with my signal
application I deployed it to to elastic
Beanstalk I configured the load balancer
to make sure that I'd sticky sessions
and boom everything kind of worked well
one thing I had to change is when it
deploys to elastic Beanstalk and you
have this sort of arbitrary PowerShell
file which you can include in the
manifest and that can affect the machine
that you land on so when you go to the
lab one thing I do is just add the
ability to open web sockets on iis
because they're not by default open so
when it deploys when elastic Beanstalk
deploys my application to a website it
opens the web sockets and signal are
just works and it was brilliant so to
show you that that app that I put it up
I've got this I've got one here so
if I've got NDC session so if you go to
this URL if anyone has an internet
connection hopefully you guys do so if
you take a photo of that QR code it'll
take me to their what should have said
let me just people should be seeing now
on their screen please wait what was
that beep that was like a server
malfunction it was like a post from a
motherboard which had gone wrong um does
anyone see this please wait was it just
me
that's so there's enough of you to prove
that this works right so in the
application I'm going to press this is a
I think it's a view j/s application and
I'm using reveal j/s to do this slides
right now if I Clos to a next slide what
should happen on your machine is you're
on your machine on your phone's you
should get a question what drink coffee
or beer and if you vote which some of
your doing it will start sending
messages now if you think when I move
the slide that sent an event that sent a
message to all of your connected phones
and basically pushed you to the correct
question when you press the button that
sends a message to everybody about your
voting and what you voted for and you'll
see as it's going it's kind of circling
around
taps rusty spaces
some quite weird going on it's a very
close call just to quickly look at the
if I just go in here and go to developer
tools and I'm just gonna refresh this I
just pop it to another screen yet and
you'll see the I have a WebSocket
connection to this thing called voting
hub this is how signal R works there
should be a negotiate somewhere that's
the HTTP request which happened to make
the negotiation with the WebSocket and
then we have this voting hub connection
which is basically our connection to our
web socket and you'll see that there's
lots of WebSocket messages which being
passed so you can actually view this in
Chrome you can look at the messages
which are passed by a WebSocket and you
can see at least it's just a piece of
JSON which is coming down and some of
them is going up and various other bits
and pieces but as people vote on the
system it will update in in real time
you'll be getting these WebSocket
notifications so that's like simple
application deploy to elastic Beanstalk
and it kind of works okay ish but
there's problems with it
and one of the problems is when you're
in a room like this and you have a
number of people connecting there's
there's only a limited number of
connections that you can have against a
single server so if I want to support
100 people I might need to maybe more
than their phone works about 1,000
people I'll probably need to service two
relatively large to relatively are
service one server probably would become
overwhelmed with connections it won't be
able to maintain enough connections to
support everyone so you can start seeing
this at this is sort of like problem
that if if you want to have more than
you know if you want to support a
thousand people or ten thousand people
or a hundred thousand people
concurrently in an experience you have
to then have a lot of servers to back
that up and it becomes more complicated
because there's still this connection
between the client and the server but
when you've got like a bank of servers
you can only communicate with the other
clients which are connected to the same
server you can't communicate if
if it was a chat application let's say
and you were connected via via this
system you'd be connected to one server
and I couldn't chat to anyone on in any
other of servers like there was no way
of passing messages between the
different services just sort of one way
so to solve that problem signal R has a
capability of adding a thing called a
back plane and the back planes like a
addition it's a distributed pub/sub
system of some description
I don't quite know why exactly but but
Redis was always picked as the the way
that they did in signal I'll you did
that did it but it has not only a cache
it's also has a pub/sub mechanism that
you can use and basically it means that
and this backplane will make sure that
messages not only get passed between
will get passed between the different
the servers so if you were building a
chat application you can be sure that if
you sent a message to one server that
message would then get redistributed
across all of the servers and all as
many other services you want it to but
now we're getting more complicated we've
got a load balancer we need quite a big
cluster of machines depending on how
many people we need to support and then
we need this backplane well that's a big
cluster that's got a number of machines
if I want high availability I need at
least three machines and all of a sudden
I've got quite an expensive system for a
voting application it's becoming quite
difficult to justify this potentially
and so to add signal our support by the
way to Redis it's really straightforward
in your MVC application you basically
where you would ordinarily in in the
services right services but I'd signal
are you just also include don't add
Stack Exchange Redis because it's this
using the the open source Redis
connection which has been developed by
Stack Exchange and then point it to your
ready server provide it with a channel
prefix because often you'll be using a
backplane across multiple applications
so you use a channel to do the sub pub
and then that's it you don't have to
like set any servers repair anything
signal I'll just Matt is magic this is
why I think David thalys Fowler's a
genius but it's like it's it's so simple
to set up and make it distributed that
it's pretty cool
but it doesn't stop it being expensive
if you want to scale it out it starts
being complicated
there's lots of things that can go wrong
and generally the projects that I've
worked on based on signal are stuff goes
wrong lots you know it's very difficult
to keep this stuff working and running
smoothly so I was at reinvent in 2018 I
was watching a session by people which
are completely unrelated to the kind of
work that I was doing but they were
honest they were talking about service
applications they're saying I'm really
interested in this concept of service
applications service applications being
applications that you construct out of
functions these lambda functions in AWS
this case which have small pieces of
business logic and then you use
something which stands in front of those
those pieces of logic which then
distribute distributes the requests in
most cases in lots of cases in AWS we
use a thing called a API gateway an API
gateway sits in front of our lambdas and
sort of or all maybe not just our
lambdas it can sit in front of our
containerized application you can sit in
front of any kind of application and it
can do some interesting stuff like it
could it can take a request in it could
convert that request and send out to a
system or it could modify the request
coming in and send different requests to
different systems or it could and get
the response coming back from the system
and convert it in some way maybe it
could transform it into a different
thing and then send it out to something
else so you have it the API gateways
like a real sort of interesting sort
proxy gateways it's a gateway it's a
really interesting gateway forum for
designing api's and what they did it
reinvent 2018 was they not this was
usually for rest api's what they
announced was this capability of
WebSocket support and they said well
we're gonna allow API gateway is now
going to have WebSocket support so your
clients will connect to WebSockets to
Web API gateway and then that will send
information to to us it blew my mind is
to like how this even works and so this
is roughly the basis of what I'm going
to be explaining to you and showing you
how you can we are connected like this
to use a managed service like WebSockets
and within the API gateway obviously you
go without saying the alize p.i gateway
has been built from the ground up for
scale and some of our customers are
enormous
in terms of the scaling and of what they
do and many of our customers are using
our API gateway to build our
applications so now of the gate what
you'll find with gateways that it should
be able to support most kinds of
workloads and and and you should be able
to do lots of different lots of many
sort of concurrent requests coming in at
the same time and it shouldn't really
falter there are limits and service
limits obviously attached to so the
websocket api
and and we there's some of them are soft
limits and some of them are hard limits
that we can remove but for the most part
for the kinds of applications that I
build I don't even touch but I don't
even scare it slightly in terms of its
scalability and so the way that this
programming model works is you have
Amazon API WebSockets a gateway
WebSockets API which is like this
managed service that you pay for
effectively which sits there waiting for
requests to come in
you have your i/o our iot devices your
dashboard your chat applications your
mobile applications rather than
connecting to a signal our hub inside
your application it connects to a
WebSocket which is hosted and managed by
this system when a request comes in it
is sent to other back-end stuff it could
be a lambda function it could be a
regular API it could be whatever compute
you've got there what's important is
that it state its stateless the the back
end the back end has no concept of that
it's working in real time it doesn't use
WebSockets at all it's just being
invented via rest or by a invocation by
the Gateway so the Gateway is doing all
the clever things about maintaining the
the state full connections and your
application can just sit there in bliss
working stateless Lee and obviously
because of that it's much easier to
scale those sorts of applications so the
way it works if if you build an API and
you get a WebSocket
endpoint this is a secure socket WSS
you'll get some unique ID execute that
API the region Amazon DWS calm and then
the stage so you might have like
different stages production development
tests or whatever and so your
applications will connect up into the
IPA gateway API gateway and when
message comes into the API gateway it
gets transferred to some back-end
service now you can you can basically
route any request to any system but in
this example I'm going to route it to a
service back-end built in lambda so it
will invoke it but what's interesting is
when it invokes it it comes along with a
connection ID and that connection ID
uniquely identifies the user which sent
the request so you end up with an invoke
a connection ID and then what I do in my
application is when they connect I store
that that connection ID in a in a cache
or in a database actually I use dynamo
DB so I just take the connection IDs and
put them in a database table so now
anyone which connects to my application
I've got this long list of all the
people which are connected to it so
that's cool one one one client is being
able to connect to the application and
they'll be able to send messages to the
API gateway and if they send like over
the WebSocket three WebSocket messages
that gets translated as three
invocations of my lambda function so my
lambda function doesn't just get sent
three messages it gets invoked three
times so it's completely stateless on
this side and it gets passed this
connection ID lambda function I store
some stuff in dynamo DB in my in my when
it connects so we've got one-way
communication of the way so how does the
lambda function speak to these people
well it uses this connection ID the API
gateway provides a thing called a
connection URL and a connection URL
gives you the unique name eight execute
API uswest one Amazon dearest calm
environment connections and then you can
pass a connection ID and if you pass
that connection ID it's like a rest
endpoint you can call it and you can
send messages to it and what will happen
is that's being sent to API gateway API
gateway will take that rest that
information that map that message and it
will route it to the WebSocket
connection of that connection ID so it
will start routing messages back and
forth so it's doing all the heavy
lifting of maintaining the WebSocket
connections and you're just using rest
basically to send message
to those different connections and the
way that you basically pick different
users is by the connection ID so that
connection URL has a couple of features
one is you can post to it which means
that you send a message from the server
to the client the other thing you can do
is you can get you can do a get request
and it would basically say what the last
known state of that that that WebSocket
is and because obviously WebSockets
disconnect all the time so you might
want to know if it's been disconnected
if it's still active or not or you might
actively want to say I don't want them
to be connected anymore I want to delete
them from the service so I'm going to
delete or disconnect their WebSocket
connection for whatever reason so it's a
rest api you can set a post get or
delete to it and it will either send a
message it will get the status or it
will delete the WebSocket connection so
if I want to create one of these things
I go into the API gateway console I say
I want to create an API I choose a web
socket API I give the API a name I use a
route selection expression this is how
we route the request coming in to the
correct portion of our system so the
request dot body might message the
request up body message is even in a
video I'll make mistakes and request
stop body message is where we store the
routing information
so basically when we just when we
customer when we create on our craft our
message that will be if we pass in the
route connect it will connect to this
thing and we're saying we're gonna
integrate with a lambda function and
we're gonna send it over to this
particular lambda function I've
obviously uploaded a lambda function
previously on connection function okay
so when they connect they're gonna call
that lambda function when the WebSocket
disconnects like when the browser sends
a disconnection command it's going to
call this function and then I want to
create a a send message route so when
they want to send the message I want to
create a way of sending a message so I
create a new route
and I'd basically say I want to pass
that over to a lambda function I could
pass that over to anything it could be a
docker container it could be kubernetes
it could be whatever I'm going to pass
it over to a send message function and
then I go and deploy that API I create a
new stage I'll say I want to put on
production or prod the idea of me
deploying anything to production anymore
is laughable but let's give it a little
description you don't actually need to
do that but we deploy it and then what
will happen is you get that WebSocket
URL at the top your URL you can just
basically start using that from any
client which supports WebSockets and the
connection URL which you can start using
inside of your lambda functions to sort
of execute and pass information back and
forth so like the way that you craft
these headers all these messages in the
WebSockets is really important so this
one this message would be routed to the
send message lambda function and the
data that's going to be transferring
over is hello MDC so my lambda function
will basically get that piece of data
and it can do something with it if this
was a chat application it might store
that information in a database it might
decide to distribute to that to
everybody in the in the in the channel
or whatever but it's the lambda function
which actually does the clever stuff
potentially so I end up with an
architecture like this so rather than
having a single my single application
I've got an API gateway and the routes
based upon the action header or the
message header which is called about
earlier and when someone connects to the
device that when they create a web
socket it creates by default it's on
connect event that will get sent to the
on connect lambda what I do is I take
the connection ID and I store in a
database and that's all I do with it and
then when they connect and they want to
send a message I go to send a message
and I take their message that they're
sending and I get a list of all the
current connections and I basically loop
through every connection and post each
connection the message and it gets
distributed to everybody that makes
sense and I've got one last lambda
function which does a disconnect and
basically if you call that with a
connection ID it says disconnect I'll
remove your
or connection ID from the database so
this database should be basically a
growing and decreasing list of all the
current connections which I can call so
from my application I can call any
anyone which is connected with you know
from any system as long as I can access
the connection IDs I can just call them
so it's stateless it's stateless in the
way you do this or model of it I just
quickly show you if you I don't know for
you so a lambda function looks something
like that and if you want to know how I
did that I'll maybe tear over a bit
later but a lambda function looks like
this basically so it's a function and
there's an input there's a lambda
context and this particular function
just returns input to upper so upper
cases whatever gets sent to it like it's
really simple business logic that would
be the worst lambda function in the
world but it's something you could do
right so my application my send message
application it does a little bit it's a
little bit more complicated I'm not
going to go into exactly what it what it
does it basically does DynamoDB gets all
the connection IDs and then over on over
somewhere here yeah online to 674 it
loops through all the connections and it
posts the message to all of the
different connections so my send message
lambda function is quite straightforward
it gets a list of connections it takes
the message and it posts the message to
all of the connected clients so let's
see if this works so this is a live chat
this one is yeah it's lunch at dot the
Biebs now I've created this little sort
of demo sting where I can actually paste
any WebSocket connection I prepaid it
with one which it currently exists and
if you go to a chat dot the Biebs dotnet
and click connect it connects up to that
WebSocket URL and then hopefully it
should work yeah yeah other people have
figured out how to work this as well so
you've gone to that URL and you're
typing in your message your connects
that WebSocket and now stuffs
yo-yo-yo-yo blah hello NDC data sent so
stuff is sapling this is all using those
three lambda functions it's a and this
basically serve server stateless
application so this is just a HTML page
god this is really dangerous isn't it
we're safe
yeah
so we've got we've got the this
application this is just a view jeaious
application it's I can host this in s3
you know AWS and I can host it on
anything which supports some you know
static websites is 120 yeah so I don't
need anything very complicated to host
this kind of applications it's just
static websites and that's what's
interesting about my blazer web assembly
is I can compile that to just run on
anything which hosts static websites so
I host my blazer webassembly
applications on a thing called amplify
console which is like a little DevOps
thing where I basically connect up and
github to amplify console it deploys or
builds my blazer application it then
deploys it to a s3 it puts a cloud front
in front of it it then connects a SSL
certificate and so that I've got
basically this hosted free SSL website
and it cost nothing or very very little
pennies to run every month and that's
how I post my Blaser applications at the
moment my what my webassembly blazer
applications and so I was looking at
blazer I was thinking well how could I
build something like this in blazer and
like what would I need to do and what's
the sort of what's a sort of journey
which which which I have to go on to get
that to work so I don't if you've looked
much into blazer I started looking -
about a year ago just interested really
I follow Steve Sanderson religiously and
ever since he wrote that what rocks MVC
three book and also when he wrote
knockout J s like I was writing a lot of
knockout stuff so I was I was really
following Steve and he was talking to
the awful lot about blazer he actually
spoke at an event that I ran in 2015
where he showed web assembly and showed
the idea that you could compile C C++
into into something which could execute
and run in the browser so he can pre
compiled on stage for as sequel Lite and
ran it in the browser and it kind of
blew my mind a little bit and then he
just said Frank at the end he says I've
kind of got this idea that maybe you
could run a managed language in this you
know if you're crazy enough to do that
and these turns out that he was the
crazy enough guy to go do that
and he built this whole concept that now
you can run dotnet in webassembly in the
browser with no plugins and it's just
executing inside the browser c-sharp
executing in the browser it's on the big
fan of blazer webassembly they also have
another thing called blazer server which
is the same sort of concept but it uses
signal R to do the actual Porsche the
rendering of certain portions of it I'm
not so familiar with this this this this
hosting model and it would they're using
signal are here not really
not necessarily to do real-time
communications what they're doing is
taking advantage of the low latency of
WebSockets to be able to pass back and
forth between the server and the
server's rendering stuff so it's a bit
like a server client rendering model but
they're doing little bits at a time over
a web socket and it's rendering the
stuff on the back and passing it through
the browser so there's two different
ways you can build stuff I'm
particularly interested in this blazer
webassembly I think that's where the
interesting stuff happens and I think
this sounds like a scaling like I don't
know how that works or if it will but
anyway so I thought well how do I take
that application I built their coffee
versus beer or tabs versus spaces and
how would I because that's built-in
signal now by the way that's not built
using this lambda function sort scenario
and it's not used using blazer it using
for UJS how do I do that in Blazer so I
started going on this journey and I went
to Blazer lil client apps with c-sharp
who wouldn't love doing that I was a
buyer I bought Silverlight so I'm
definitely gonna buy this mat and that
went great I mean I went great
so dotnet knew I had to do in the
installation of the templates to get a
blazer webassembly working so I've got
that new mugshot page but not Carol you
can read that command and then you can
run a template or create a base template
application by saying blazer new blazer
wasm wise them I think this is this is
some form of its web assembly but I'm
not quite sure what that stands for
why is them but sounds like an insult
Blazer wisdom and then I've give my
application a name
and that'll Kate like a skeleton
application the only thing I modified in
this application was to start with was
data so that that version will show you
how you go and do a fetch from a website
so I added questions JSON and I stored
the questions hard-coded into my
application temporarily okay and the
idea being that there's a title of the
question we've got one or two answers
we've got one or two pictures and then
the number of counsel the number of
people took voted for each option so
I've got two questions in my application
at the moment and then I went to the
pages element and liked the model the
working model of Blazer is that you have
these play these these pages and they
almost almost have a like a lifecycle
they're templates but they have like a
lifecycle each one on them and it's
already wired up but basically if I go
to my website slash nothing like no root
and I don't give it a URL we'll go to
this page which says hello world and if
I went to slash questions it would go to
the questions not raised if I went to a
slash vote it would go to the vote page
and there's a whole routing system
obviously to do that we're not going to
get into any of that I just wanted to
show you that all I did was I modified
the raise of views and changed one to
the index I didn't modify that I've got
one called questions and one called vote
now idea questions is like that screen
which shows the question or the slides
in my other example and then the vote is
the ability for people to then vote on
the options so I've got two screens I'll
enter needed to develop so on the
initializations there's a life cycle of
these pages and you have this on initial
eight uninitialized async and that's
that happens when the page loads so I
basically say my questions object I'm
going to populate that with these it's
doing a fetch request but effectively
it's my local JSON file my questions and
what will happen is I get an object a
questions object which is a list of
questions which is a C solid C sharp
object at this point and I can start
using out my application now the cool
thing about this is it's like a single
page application in the if I edit the
questions if I if I attach that to the
screen and then edit the questions add
questions delete questions modify
questions my screens gonna update
automatically just like it would in
angular just like it would in react so
you basically work with the data on this
side and just somehow magic
through the power of wisdom it somehow
updates your screen and so forth and all
of this stuff happens in c-sharp so
you're able to at this point write
everything in c-sharp and you'll see
that I've got a question object and it's
basically taking my Jason request it's
doing a cast into a question object and
I've got a list of questions which I
then combine to so in my application to
do some binding I basically put a header
which says questions and I say well if
the questions is null like if there's
nothing if there's no question object
it's nothing in there then just put
loading because that's probably going to
be fetching some data but when there is
some questions then display a table and
it's just a table which has got title
and - 102 2 + 2 1 count answer to count
and then in that view I've got a little
bit more
you noticed that at the top there on
online - I've got an injector
the HTTP client so I'm using certain
clients and certain imports so I'm
injecting the HTTP client is like a
dependency injection so I can do the
fetch of that to get that data and
you'll see that in the top you can like
use usings to use different dll's and so
forth as well and then I have this
little piece of logic which basically
says for each question just loop through
loop through and print out the table but
it does a really crude thing which says
I store this variable called current
current count or current question and if
it's the current question then show the
current question if it's not then hide
it so I'll only ever show one question
at a time on the screen and then I've
got at the bottom here two buttons can't
we see them very well here but they're
just buttons and I've got these at on
click previous question next question
and that's wiring it up to - event
handlers which are going to handle those
button clicks and those button clicks
event handlers those are they just look
just looks like HTML I guess in it but
it's but this thing this this event it's
going to fire as a c-sharp thing I've
got next question and next question in
previous question and I have some really
basic logic which says if current count
is less than questions length then
increment the current counts or
increment this variable and if the
current count is less than one that
increment decrease the current count
comment what the word is and live mine
um so what means but just by changing
this current count because my views
attached to that current count variable
as I move as I do that it's basically
going to be changing the question that's
visible on screen so you see that if
current count that that will change
based upon me changing the current count
so it'll be reevaluated the screen and
redrawing the screen and every time I
press those two buttons it's really
simple to start like changing the UI
using something like blazer so if I go
into questions this is the screen I just
created effectively
and I can go next in previous and it's
just incrementing that one value and
because my views attached to that value
it's updating the current question which
is visible right straight forward no
problem so far now I wanted to create a
voting screen so I've got my questions
which are gonna be shown to the audience
now I want a voting screen that people
are going to go on their mobile
application they're going to vote so
this is it's a very similar view and
it's exactly the same questions that I'm
importing but I'm just showing slightly
different things I'm showing the title
answer one answer too and I'm creating
two buttons on the screen and those
buttons are basically attached to either
vote answer one or vote answer to which
of these events which are which are
handling and I've also got previous and
next on here as well so it's very it's a
very similar view but it's just slowing
it slightly differently so now if I
click on next or previous and I've got
these two buttons which currently don't
do anything when I click them what I
want to happen is when I click that
button it sends a WebSocket request to
my WebSocket service that someone's
voted so there is apparently a nicer way
to do what I'm about to show you I'm
Steve Sanderson told me about it
yesterday and I spent the vast majority
of last night trying to get it to work I
failed so apparently you can now use the
actual solid WebSocket WebSocket thing
inside of net inside a blazer
application but at the time when I was
writing this you couldn't so what I was
doing was saying well WebSocket exists
in JavaScript so I will just create the
WebSocket there and then I'll do this
Interop between the c-sharp and
JavaScript and this is how Interop works
in Blazer so in that same initialization
what I've got is I in I use this j/s
runtime invoke async and I call a
JavaScript helper function which is on
the page and I pass the information
about the URL that I want to connect to
and I create a reference back to this
particular object
I have these luckily I'm still ok with
JavaScript so I'll write a little bit of
JavaScript helper functions all this
this is almost identical to what I had
to write a view to do the WebSocket
communication I've got a connect
function I've got a disconnect I've got
a vote function the connect function
creates a WebSocket and then what you'll
see is when the WebSocket gets a message
like so when someone sends a message to
the WebSocket I invoke the c-sharp and
once I want to say in the back end it's
not in the back end it's in the front
end but it's weird it so it's invoking
the web assembly JavaScript so this is
like a bit of an interplay you should
have to be able to not have to do this
in future versions I believe this should
just be all wind net inside the handler
but at the moment I'm having to
interrupt with JavaScript and the
reality of Blaser is that you have to
interact with that JavaScript so it's
quite good to learn how to do it anyway
and I've also got this function called
vote which I can call from the from from
c-sharp and that will basically just
send the message to the socket so
JavaScript now maintaining this web
socket and I'm interrupting between
c-sharp and JavaScript to actually go
and send the messages so I have these
two buttons on my screen they're
attached to these two c-sharp handlers
and the c-sharp and the vote one all it
does is just invokes that piece of
JavaScript vote to invoke another piece
of JavaScript if I was writing this with
the new version or the new way of doing
it I would just be invoking on the web
socket which exists in wiesen are not in
JavaScript and then when a when a some
message comes in to my system like
someone else's voted and I'm receiving
the message that they have voted it will
through that little magic that I've just
created it will invoke this c-sharp
function and this c-sharp function
creates a little object it takes the
information it counts and it basically
updates the status of the the vote count
or in the application so there was a
little bit of plumbing which completely
like I hate the Plumbing's horrible to
be honest but Blaser is beautiful when
you are in the c-sharp aspect of it and
you're just dealing with that and you
like realize oh my gosh I've got lists
and like generics and like oh this is
insanely clever but then it's not so
great when you have to sometimes invoke
JavaScript and think about context and
stuff like that so what I did is I
created on my
the same service because I'm lazy I
created another handler called vote and
I passed that vote to a different lambda
function and this lambda function
basically does very similar thing to
send message but it's specifically for
voting so it just takes the vote
information and then distributes the
vote to all of the connected clients so
it works in a similar way as the other
lambda function so a message comes in to
this service it will be routed into the
lambda pump function the vote lambda
function so when someone clicks on the
button a message vote with a question ID
of an answer ID will be sent over to my
web api gateway via WebSocket this is
what my don't expect you to read that
this is what my WebSocket that my lambda
function looks like basically it's
reading from the database getting the
connection IDs and then posting the vote
to all of the connected clients this is
the this is the way that I do this this
marshalling between JavaScript and C
sharp so I've got this on socket on
message and it invokes this on on vote
Becket message ultimately the vote
request comes in two to this so as
people are voting and your application
will be receiving the c-sharp function
calls and then when I modify this the
status the screen sometimes I have to
call this thing called state has changed
and sometimes I don't and I'm not really
an expert in Blaser life cycle to
understand when I need to call it them
and how but sometimes the UI doesn't
update based upon if you've changed
objects sometimes you're not in a
position where that's going to do an
update of the screen but if you call
state has changed then it kind of makes
the screen dirty and and it will do a
rerender so I call that after modifying
that and what that creates is then I've
just been in chrome here I've got my
WebSocket connection connected up and as
I'm pressing the button you'll see that
messages are getting sent over to the
server and they're also being
distributed to everyone which is
connected as well so that's the
WebSocket basic sort of setup so to
prove that it actually works
Peg's we've connected
I've put two browsers next to each other
one which is on the question screen and
ones on the voting screen and when you
vote tabs you should see like I think
this is getting incremented in the other
browser so the other connected client is
getting and receiving the WebSocket
messages and updating information as it
is that is the same almost the exactly
the same underlying technology as I've
got in my voting application and signal
are but what's really important about
all of this is if you think the
infrastructure required to run something
like this compared to what I had to do
with say signal are I can host the
website the Blazer website in a static
web hosting thing I could host it on
github I could host it end like anywhere
which supports static web hosting I
connect to the WebSocket URL which has
got an API gateway so I'll be paying for
the API gateway and and that requirement
and you pay based upon number of
transactions how many messages are
passed so you pay saint-like under $1
for a million requests for example and
then the lambda functions well they
don't
that's not infrastructure that I manage
at all they only sit there and get
invoked and I pay for the invocation so
if it gets invoked I pay for the amount
of computer use I think you get like a
million transactions free in lambda
every month so you know you could build
an example like this the demo that I
would I'm building here cost me zero to
host nothing to host and the cool thing
is when I go away and it's not used
which is quite often okay it's not used
I'm really paying nothing because
nothing's getting used no lambda cap
functions are getting called the API
gateway is getting called I'm paying the
pennies that's required by my static
code hosting and now that could be the
static HTML code hosting and that could
literally be in any provider on any
cloud providers hosting system and the
other thing which is cool about it is
when I actually host it in say amplified
console as a static coaster
I have like a DevOps build so I
basically check my application into
github it does a real simple build off
of that github repository it creates the
static assets in Blaser it pushes it to
a website because I'm an AWS customer
and my domains registered through route
three then my I get you get three SSL
Certificates so basically and all of my
domains are free as well and so it means
that you can start you know hosting this
stuff fro very cheaply but also getting
SSL certificates which don't expire and
underfed fundamentally building websites
which which of interactive and highly
scalable like at moment's notice this
could scale to you know a bit a really
big sort of audience and it shouldn't it
shouldn't fall over it won't fall over
mine it won't fall over and if it did it
would be my fault in not AWS is I'm
positive of that but so that's what's
really interesting about it I'm paying
nothing when it's idle and I'm only ever
paying if it's successful and I think
that's a really interesting model for
real time at something which previously
wasn't possible with with other models
of building real time applications just
to let you know we have a whole team
which work on dotnet AWS I am just one
of these these people I'm a principal
advocate which means I go around and
speak about the dotnet support in AWS
but there is a ton of other people built
in the back on the back row there and
various other people just here today
from AWS and then there's a whole team
back in Seattle and globally and which
do dotnet on AWS we have thousands and
thousands of customers which you've net
on AWS not our job is to try and make it
better than it was before so how trying
to make the experience on a double it's
the best place to run net it on the
planet and that's our that's our
objective and what we're really keen to
do so if you're interested in running on
AWS and you're not sure how to do it
come speak to us at the booth we're on
level three at the back and if you're
interested in changing the face of the
world come and work for us we're hiring
dotnet developers and we'd lots of
different roles throughout the
organization and we can tell you about
that on the stand as well and also if
you just come and speak to us we'll give
you a raffle ticket and you might win a
an echo show v I think we run a raffle
every day at 3 o'clock so come speak to
us come talk to us about dotnet thank
you very much indeed
one last thing if you could use this
system to vote for to vote first to see
how the session went oh it gives me
instant feedback please just tell me how
you thought about the session and give
me any comments and so forth about it
and there's also the NBC kind of you
know green red thing at the back and
just to let you know if you're not
familiar with it if you love the session
you think it's fantastic you think it's
great you think I've been great then you
just put a green green piece of card in
that board thing if you think that the
sessions been terrible and do come and
speak to me and what you want to do at
the end is you want to put a green thing
in that bin laughter thank you very much
indeed Cheers
[Applause]